[Music]
in nightmare neighbor news all [ __ ] no I
live in apartments so you have many why
have a lot of neighbors you are the
nightmare day before the nightmare oh
you know who the nightmare is just
garbage collector no shima dream for the
neighbors the garbage collector and the
construction people cuz they are loud
yeah they're loud but our place
the neighbors are cute except for when
people are fighting about rent and [ __ ]
like that I've heard some [ __ ] oh the
neighbors you yeah for sure especially
have a crack door it's my neighbor
apartment across the street which is not
associated to all or bujji side and we
walk by like when we walk the dog man
all the [ __ ] you said you go pay my
[ __ ] rent all right submitted by
Camilla planning I know it's like a
caramel a dad claims his neighbor is
terrorizing his children with an alarm
that only people under 25 can hear it's
like a dog yeah Gina do you hear Yanni
are loyal just like that high-pitched
doggie thing you know how only doggies
couldn't hear the frequency and then
they don't like it that's exactly what
it is it's this alarm that looks like
this
that's this nightmare neighbor installed
in her home two facing it in the same
direction as this man that has I think
six kids how do they know that since
well how do they know that's what it's
for
yeah what are the kids act like oh
that's your boy I was like what the
boughs farting no I thought it was an
earthquake all that the building's
moving
so great why did they set up the alarm
for so this woman she is a [ __ ] so she
set up this alarm that has a frequency
that only people under 25 could hear so
this man who's 52 years old hat says
that his kids there he's had to hospital
like some of these kids because of the
noise like my god my [ __ ] ears won't
like put a high pitch like a dog whistle
type of thing yeah I wish I could hear
because alder the older you get the less
higher frequencies you can hear when you
hear the ringing in your ear that goes
tonight like that you know what that
means
that's a frequency dying oh yeah when
you hear the ring yeah when you hear it
that's that's what it is it's a it's a
Oh won't be here be able to hear that
pitch anyway
there's no one that's so interesting
yeah we should I sit here though all the
time after going Rea me yeah uh would be
ringing for the next three hours and I'm
like damn my hearing is getting [ __ ]
up imagine my life Goga dancing every
weekend yeah every night I came home
Walter we're gonna be those [ __ ] old
people that I owe
I hope to goodness the technology is
better by that way they have cochlear
implants and stuff now you know what's
funny my dad has his hearing aids right
and then a one time he comes over to
like play with tyka and then her mom is
like yelling at him like Ana's like talk
to him and he just can't hear her and
then finally like okay your mom was
talking like and I was like dad the
battery's dying he's like huh have to go
like this close and he's like I think my
batteries died would you yell oh I'm
sorry and I'm like I think that's what
everyone's been trying to tell you
yeah it's calmer fix um you know when
you're in a nightclub and you're trying
to talk to someone you don't need to
yell in their ear cuz you just get
really close
not normally so there's this awesome
texture raver technique Oh No
so you see this little piece of yeah
yeah so he closes that and then he yells
yeah see I wish bit like guys gonna hit
on man clubs like [ __ ] like chill like
it ya think it like gets into your
eardrum and you're like eight clubs
thank you for reminding bees music
nightclubs and we can get concert dance
I don't want to deal with the booze [ __ ]
and then I go and I see the crowd I'm
like I'm just too much people what's
wrong the garage well we went to the
studio 71 party and did the dancing
dolls kind of fun yeah boughs it
neighbor she looks like a [ __ ] don't
touch my petunias yeah and this is the
dad who has six kid he's like that one
that's a white ass house I would have
shot it with a BB gun torini it looks
like it looks like it's really nice I
believe is in the UK does she turn it on
because the kids are always so [ __ ]
loud all the time so she said that it's
perfectly legal and that it has been
authorized by this council and the
police and she set it up because of
vandalism and harassment she has faced
from that family as what she claimed
vandalism well they're gonna keep
vandalism so she said I can't here [ __ ]
for you so Thomas which is a single dad
he has six kids six kids dude snippet
already he don't use condoms yeah you're
lucky was weakest [ __ ] so he's renting
this four-bedroom apartment which is
behind the property of this nightmare
neighbor and so she angled that alarm so
behind her house and so she's claiming
that some of these kids were throwing
bottles at her home
yeah they're really loud and I don't
know but the landlady of Thomas's house
who's owned that property for the last
14 years said that he isn't the first
person to have problems with his
neighbors Oh this neighbor I mean that
she has had three tenants that left
because of that neighbor mm-hmm so she
is I would trust that she's a [ __ ] yeah
okay there's a lot of ways to handle
kids and I don't think tormenting dad
sound is one of them we got hops
hospitalized yeah like he took some of
them to the hospital before damn well
took him to hospital hospitalized maybe
didn't to get the ears checked
this is the quote the alarm makes them
scream in pain I even had to take my
daughter to the hospital because their
ears didn't stop ringing Oh sue her for
that no yeah but then he's saying like
they live in a beautiful beautiful place
but the kids are like prisoners and he
doesn't want to move out because he
loves her he lives it's just the fact
that that alarm and like she turns it on
I could not live with that yeah and then
like whenever you have to get out of the
house like they're in pain they just got
to get the Bose QuietComfort are the
ones that you go shooting with oh yeah
oh do that and just some of the kids
outside and having playing scream scream
louder let me see for fun mm-hmm and if
that's her reasoning then they should
keep and they should throw bottles at
her house because if she's like I'm
doing this because you throw bottles at
your husband no one's throwing bottles
well then start throwing bottles yeah
what if it was another neighbor that
threw it but she targeted the kid
probably there's no proof if she's
turning it on in my day yeah no not
every day so she said that she's an
awarded teacher of 15 years and that the
alarm has been on four times in three
years because objects were being hurled
at her property for a maximum of five
minutes at a time
what then then they're not really
prisoners then yeah I feel like
sometimes teachers are the most evil
people in the world he's claiming that
she only turned it on four times in
three years but the dad is saying
otherwise we need security cameras for
this [ __ ] I want to see the judge just
knock it down at night
because imagine you buy a house and then
you're like you can't control who lives
in front who lives in the side and
you're so close to them oh my god I
don't know I wouldn't know what to do
I'd be I'd be so panicked have you guys
I'm having really bad neighbors
I feel like we have I think we are the
bad neighbors I think my neighbor Nell
is a dumbass he doesn't know how his
security system works cuz every few days
or so I hear the security alarm go off I
know who you're talking about right like
when I first yeah that house [ __ ]
whatever when I first moved in I was
like what the [ __ ] I would call a
complicated think of something wrong and
then by like the third good citizen I
swear I really am like I am very
vigilant in my neighborhood I'm not I'm
like damn I hope they're all right I
love that neighborhood by the way it's
quiet but like by the time a third like
the third or fourth time and went off on
you know what [ __ ] if you die you die
it's your fault in time you know like I
don't know how do you not know how to
set off your alarm our last apartment
complex someone would always pull the
fire alarm
just for fun yeah yeah so annoying who s
there were like not really kids in the
complex though it's I don't know but
they were like young 20 year old
prankster yeah well yeah I know I really
do think we were the bad neighbors just
cuz um which house oh yeah so when he
first moved in with me I had three other
roommates with mother or I was with my
friends and then when they would go to
work and I would go to work he [ __ ]
play the drums [ __ ] loud this guy
would get the [ __ ] but that's perfect
because everyone's at work from 9:00 to
5:00 that's the best time to be loud oh
dude okay so kind of not our direct
neighbors but the like so there's like
we're over a corner unit and then the
lot right next to us is belongs to the
next complex over but like the people
that Park in that law is an open lot and
it's kind of surrounded by buildings so
it creates this like amphitheater
this dude like details his car every
weekend like an SUV car for hours like
I'm talking like five hours and he plays
the loudest Mexican music I've ever
loved the like loudly you think there's
a [ __ ] concert going on next door
like it's like you can I had headphones
and I was right out of my video I had
headphones in and everything I couldn't
it sounded like there was a speaker
right next to me oh you're describing
every Mexican name yeah especially in
the weekends girl yeah yeah so I mean
that's probably the loudest music that
I'm right now I never listen to yeah and
Mexicans know the right brands to buy
that bumps yeah like they always have
the most bunt and [ __ ] all the time so
funny though cuz he has a couple songs
on there that are like mainstream
English hits like like total in the
green day come on
and he'll skip it I walk alone their
rope skip was nother there's no other
song huh but
that's one of the main chord progression
it's actually pretty than that it's like
a Spanish restaurant like a Mexican food
restaurant we're like it's like no I
don't know that is the only Italian
space agency our accent
[Music]
[Applause]